every time there's a mass shooting every
time there's a discussion about gun
safety regulations every time the Second
Amendment comes up you have a portion of
the gun fetishists that I talked about
on yesterday's program who say very
simply the Second Amendment is absolute
they say it is unconstitutional and it
is illegal to restrict ownership of
types of weapons and usually this is in
the context of assault-style weapons
right this is not a conversation today
about what exactly an assault weapon is
it's actually not relevant to today's
conversation this is about whether any
restrictions can legally be placed on
assault-style firearms or any firearms
now I've said before the pro-gun
fetishists have already lost this debate
because as soon as they say listen
random people shouldn't be allowed to
have shoulder-mounted RPGs they've
effectively already conceded that there
is some gray area there is some limit to
the arms that random citizens should be
allowed to have and once you concede
that it's just a matter of where you
draw the line right so I believe that
they've actually already lost this
discussion but let's put that aside for
a second we actually have legal
precedent to look at because four courts
have already said that no the Second
Amendment does not protect assault
weapons in 2008 the Supreme Court ruled
that the right to possess a firearm is
not unlimited and those were the words
of Antonin Scalia in 2015 the Seventh
Circuit US Court of Appeals said that a
Highland Park Illinois ordinance banning
the possession of assault weapons was
perfectly legal in 2015
later in the year in 2015 the Second
Circuit US Court of Appeals said the
exact same thing about laws in New York
and Connecticut and there was also a
ruling about a year ago that's the
fourth ruling in the last 10 years on
this issue or the US Court of Appeals of
the Fourth Circuit ruled that bans on
assault style weapons are legal now me
just telling you it's legal
and courts have said it's legal I don't
think is good enough I should have to
explain to you why our assault weapons
bans or semi-automatic assault style
rifle bans why are they legal why don't
they violate the Second Amendment and
I'm going to tell you there are two
basic reasons number one is even without
being allowed to own assault weapons
your right to self-defense hasn't been
curtailed you can still get a handgun
you can still get a regular long gun to
protect yourself
even if semi-automatic assault weapons
are banned that's number one number two
the rights of individual states and
localities to ban certain types of
weapons because of the risks they pose
are completely legitimate and it does
not violate the Constitution
there is really no reasonable debate
here right limiting which firearms are
legal is just not infringing on the
Second Amendment period and it's
important not to be lulled into false
debates about this that's the key thing
I want to tell the people who are
listening the people who are watching
and you pat because I think you're
increasingly confused about this as well
if I may I hope that's not offensive to
you when this is brought up state simply
and clearly like at Thanksgiving Pat
when the right wing side of your family
says you can't restrict which guns
people can have say I'm sorry but
there's no legal question here four
courts have already agreed that limiting
firearms legality is constitutional and
since almost no one says
shoulder-mounted RPGs should be allowed
it's just a matter of deciding where we
are going to set the line I think that
it's really important not to be tricked
into even debating this because there is
no debate in terms of legal precedent
well thank you because now I'm armed not
with the gun yes knowledge to the debate
this accurately what exactly and it's
funny because everyone does seem to act
like they're a constitutional lawyer on
this issue they'll read the end of the
Second Amendment and they'll see the
right of the people to keep and bear
Arms shall not be infringed but they
don't read the 2008 DC versus Heller
decision they don't read into what
Supreme Court justices have ruled on
this it's almost like they don't
understand that
you can't simultaneously claim to be a
legal expert but say I'm not going to
ignore Court precedents and decisions
that have been made by the judicial
branch of the American government which
is very very important you can't have it
both ways if you're going to claim to be
that legal expert you have to consider
the precedent and the precedent over the
last ten years on semi-automatic assault
weapon bans is very very clear which is
their legal and you can still defend
yourself even if you're not allowed to
own or buy or possess an automatic
assault style weapon send me your
thoughts I'm on twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
vittor which is a social forecasting
game for your phone or web browsers that
allows players to come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events vitur is built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market which is a scientifically
validated way of leveraging the wisdom
of the crowd to better estimate the
likelihood of future events and there
are a ton of different topics including
politics and here's how it works you go
on the app find a future event that you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
you think is most likely to happen using
the apps in game fake currency your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points and you compete with others
who are making their own predictions to
see who's the best forecaster there's no
real money or cryptocurrency involved
and that's kind of the fun of it the
whole point is use this social network
to prove how good you are at predicting
the future I have an account on the
futur
app and I make predictions and you can
place your bets based on my predictions
as well go to futur com to sign up and
start making forecasts it's totally free
and it's available on both Android and
iOS and on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm